if we care about the children how about
constructing gender in a way that
doesn't result in record depression
suicide anxiety isolation unhappiness
regardless of lapping off your tests
today's question of the day by the way
for those watching on YouTube and who've
hit the notification but are you
receiving notifications we need to know
about half the people who've done so
have been complaining that they haven't
been receiving them you guys have been
getting these tweets so please let us
know comment below and today's rebuttal
comes to us from the borderline child
abusers and the four million subscribers
teaching children the concept of gender
at the YouTube channel cut let's get to
it what's like stereotype of a boy it
stays this obnoxious I'm sorry but we'll
have some very valuable information for
you so an immediate theme you'll notice
of this video is the open and negative
stereotyping of the male gender well at
simultaneously trying to be inclusive to
non-existent genders it's important he
didn't say hey how should a man behave
it was what would be a negative
stereotype of a male don't worry no one
does as you'll see later in the video
next clip Riley do you know what gender
is I'm trying to member how to answer
this but I don't get into trouble at
home for hate speech see you're in the
ballpark
yeah that's an answer no six-year-old
gives unless they were coached by an
angry pansexual lesbian mother and they
still key still can't get it right for
fear of the afro lesbian pansexual
beating her I like to think I underst
and a little bit of it do you know what
makes a boy a boy and what makes a girl
a girl
what are boy things couple of things the
boy is innocent States what a boy wants
to be right and maybe what we as a
society would want men to be strong
fearless she then let me squash let me
swap that down with the anecdotal in
armwrestling a five-year-old could you
imagine if this had occurred with a
child who created some painting or is
trying to expand his creative realm and
apparently said that's stupid get it out
of here kids think I want to be strong
I'm gonna arm wrestle you and she feels
proud of it so that doesn't so that
doesn't or that to my highlight reel I
beat you at five really mom how about I
give it a shot
fifteen gender difference at that point
you want to know the real biological
differences in gender let's line up one
hundred males within the average
reference range okay within a hundred
miles here of this lady and have mommy
arm-wrestle them by the way rule I
should have clarified none of them can
be five years old next clip what does it
mean to be a boy twerking I wonder where
this child could have possibly learned
that girls should twerk mom but let's
all love the negative traits of men
rights they're rude and angry but what
if we said what does it mean to be a
girl and she said you act submissive and
agreeable how would they react I can
tell you exactly how they do that how
they would react because when Jordan
Peterson sites just that scientifically
people lose their minds and call him a
figurehead of the alright out of context
mind you the point where they actually
have to re-release the interview because
it was so misleading let's go to the
next clip they used to think of the only
favorite colors girls could have was
pink and purple but I've never
right no no mom no mom not a thing
no one ever assumed or forced girls to
like only pink or purple colors that was
never a thing into having one preferred
color instead of instead of this just
chose to show you that this video and
we'll get to more statistical realities
here that are really striking and what's
dangerous about this a lot of ailable
why are you just talking about the Iran
deal this is the corrosion of Western
civilization right here when we start
targeting children and teaching them
scientific biological observable
falsehoods in the name of political
correctness
that's when you know society's jumped
the shark and the mom hears instead of
saying right because it's not right
should have she should have screamed to
that child strawman no no sweetheart
that's incorrect
I want you to agree with mom and
everything but I want you good mommy
understanding the facts we never
actually had any kind of systemically
instituted preferred colors for your jet
that wasn't a thing next clip on your
body what do you have that I don't have
[Applause]
[Music]
in this video you provided the only
correct answer cuz it went out my nose
don't drink champagne straight from the
bottle
by the way keep spoiler alert
that's the only correct answer for the
entirety of the video next clip so it's
a person with a wiener says hey I'm a
girl
what is that person a girl boy a female
behold gender identity that older boy
space is priceless right they're like
behold gender identity as though it's a
thingy hold my both and the mom laughs
although she's teaching her children
nuance that's what this whole video is
about right but the thing is they're
just trying to unseat your children
scientifically observable biology in
favor of a social agenda as we said
Moroni said that they weren't coming for
your kids yeah they're here keep it
Garrett I mean that's the that's the
moment he realized his mom was an idiot
I suspected I didn't think you were
unintelligent but I I thought you might
be a bit of a [ __ ] when you arm
wrestled my five-year-old brother to
embarrass him on national broadcast no I
just think you're also fundamentally I
don't because you're a woman just just
because you're you next clip maybe 15
minutes after you were born but oh no
and I'm learning that was just the sex
you were born that doesn't mean this is
not this isn't a trick I just know you
just know
think about it twice no but what if like
Janet is telling you you can't if I was
always just you can't be a girl you
can't be a girl your whole life you
think you would be like oh I see there
are two Christmas miss shoe Christmases
in that family there which makes sense
because at first I thought this was
gonna be the gay dad yeah but now he's
what twist I've locked with these are
the same people who will be losing their
minds when you tell your kid tell people
you take your kids to church I know you
are indoctrinating how dare you
indoctrinated up I know well here's the
thing first up couple clarifications
gender actually isn't assigned at birth
it's recognized by medical professionals
doctors because contract how a child
feels in the hair-dye aisle 15 years
down the line okay with mommy doctors
actually need to identify the sex /
gender to determine immediate care and
treatment for example the boys have
higher mortality rates during the first
year do a weaker immune system they need
more care and they cost more money and
the example that this father loses sleep
this beta male uses the exact opposite
buy this isn't a reverse now is like one
of those things you can't be a girl you
can't be a girl when the fact is it's
biology telling them sorry but you're
not a boy it's the opposite of what the
dad is saying and of course again two
Christmases which stands to reason next
clip when I was little people used to
call me tomboy and that didn't really
fit because it wasn't something that I
called myself look I felt like a little
boy when I was little hmm and then when
when I was 12 and I found out that I was
supposed to be a girl and that girl met
certain things it was kind of scary to
me because it was a box that I wasn't
ready to be put into no no no no no one
put you into a box you have one now
here's the thing
how did you feel like a boy this is
where it starts to unravel I felt like I
was a boy were you rude annoying because
that's the only example we've had of man
he remember what would you think of rude
and annoying thinking they're cool
aggressive violent we've only heard
negative male stereotypes and then she
said I felt as though I was a boy how so
how did you feel as though you were a
boy and they used to society tried to
force me into the box of being woman
doing that society tried to force you to
be what what would be the aunt in him
too rude and annoying
answer him for those don't know it's the
opposite of a synonym could it be polite
accident cordial shaming society is
forcing you to be polite and cordial
which would be considered feminine
qualities I don't understand this then
again science next clip what if you
forgot if you're a boy or a girl there
are people who don't really identify as
a boy or a girl
oh no they're in that middle space I've
real deep yes yes they're in that middle
space oh I know this one mom do you mean
like the intersex people who only make
up I think about point zero one eight
percent of the population many people
today's progressives called intersex
actually they have conditions they
really aren't confused about their
gender at all at all but they actually
have predominantly male or female
characteristics and they end up living
under one gender or another entirely
guilt free and without biological
complication is that one is that what
we're going with this mom are you
talking about intersex to a very extreme
and small example oh no next clip people
should call you your actual gender say
them should see him or not okay first up
smoke yeah yeah the two girls or none
really two young children who refuse to
acknowledge biology and now claim that
they have no gender okay who just so
happened to have a blue-haired lesbian
looking androgynous mother what are the
chances
kids you rolled the dice and that came
up snake that came up both makeup that
came up fake blue contact lens neck eyes
to match the lesbian hairdo what are the
chances as you'll see it's actually not
just happenstance because we've got some
more statistics next clip this is myself
I identify as trans non-binary so the
surgery that I'm going to have all of
this is gonna be gone how do you feel
about that
mmm got you're a psychopath perhaps mom
but she gives an answer and I actually
really do appreciate the the the earnest
answer that follows still I still have
an experience don't like feelings little
bit scary a lot scary yeah what's scary
about it namely lopping off your tail
namely that you're going to be I mean
there are lots there's a lot mother but
chief amongst them is that you will be
chopping off your tips there are many
reasons the complications the 41%
attempted suicide rate that doesn't get
any better when you have the surgery
again where you're chopping off your and
consider that American slaves and those
and internment camps never actually had
the average populace suicide rates that
were that high compared to the
transgender community
I'm I'm actually I'm actually a little
fearful mother that my mother might be
mentally unstable
biologically I mean a chemical thing
also you know the lopping off your toes
I don't want to gloss over that did you
ever want me to be non-binary when you
were litoris I just wanted you to be who
you are with
having to choose because when I grew up
there was just boy and girl
how many genders are there infinity yes
I was like is this confusing yes I have
no and betters death by this that's the
this is the point no one has ever been
able to answer when they say listen
misgendering someone this is a big thing
on campus it's an act of violence
well how many how many pronouns are
there no one can answer the question
this is a video by the way designed to
both ask and answer questions please go
watch it in its full context I think we
pretty much ran the entire video it
doesn't answer any of them because they
don't know the answers they can't even
play by their own rules and something
that's really important and this is why
this matters and I say it's actually
that it will be the downfall of Western
civilization notice anything in this
video I'm a Hmong stall of the would say
non-binary trans black lesbian even know
what you fit that into you're not trying
to identify with anything at that point
other than a psychopath um not a single
positive rail mobile no got the entirely
the nails anything else by the way they
exclusively cycle through negative male
stereotypes so what if instead of the
negative male stereotypes they actually
went through there if he said hey listen
sweetheart what do you think would be
the ideal how should a man act and then
maybe the girl goes I don't know maybe
it may be a man should be kind and
loving but firm and protective and able
to provide but also able to lead when
need be and also understand when to
submit to them I don't know that's a
good question dad and I I wonder I think
you fulfill a lot of those qualities
what if they did that instead and what
if when this made this girl disrespected
I mean I'm gonna go to mommy's house dad
you don't know anything right what if
instead of him just going take it take
it along with the alimony what if when
his girl disrespected him there on a
national broadcast what if the one man
in there said hey hey whoa hey
sweetheart watch your mouth don't talk
to dad that way
that's not how you speak to adults
that's not respectful and instead
started teaching her how she should deal
with Authority taught her how a people
should interact sociologically and then
how women should act and then how men
should treat women to properly what if
instead of all of the things they did
they did all of that and said and by the
way
what are the chances anything else you
notice what are the chances that these
kids outpace the average as far as
gender non-binary kids by like 100% the
odds are very favorable and something I
don't understand that and hopefully we
get someone to know we had a dropout
tomorrow for a long-form debate if
gender is a societal construct as which
which is the presupposition of this
entire video gender societal construct
how about if we're going to acknowledge
that and we're going to say please do I
have to get rid of this hat please do it
for the children right please do it it's
a societal construct let's well let's
care about the children let's create
videos like this cut okay if we care
about the children how about
constructing gender in a way that
doesn't result in record depression
suicide anxiety isolation unhappiness
regardless of lapping off your toes
chief amongst some reasons for you being
unhappy that you cut off your tips
mother if we're going to say it's a
societal construct and we know beyond
any shadow of a doubt statistically that
the transgender community both pre-op
and post-op have record rates of
depression suicide anxiety why don't we
construct something if we're cuz we're
teaching our kids something anyway as
you're trying to do here if we're going
to teach them something
how about teaching them a way of life
that we know leads to not only better
health for themselves but for the rest
of their families subscribe watch one of
these other videos or hit the
notification Bell well you should hit
that if you subscribe anyways because
subscriptions don't mean anything on
YouTube anymore now you have to get
notifications that it shows up in your
inbox so I don't know why you subscribe
in the first place because we have to do
also making money off these videos
anymore because YouTube decided why they
just said we're not going to and when we
said why they didn't tell us why exactly
imagine if you [ __ ] up to your job deal
you work and then they said hey by the
way we're not gonna pay you said why
they said piss off